bon allez vous qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer bon alors j'ai une petite
confession à vous faire dans cette fatwa
a pris des distances géographiques
géographe voir qu'est donc elle s'est
déplacée
donc c'est ma première saint valentin
sol depuis six places et oui à tout
quitter la france
oui c'est vrai quoi oui oui pour un
motif impérieux mais elle va revenir
donc pour cette saint valentin
oui c'est nancy risuddin au chalet je ne
suis pas confiant j'ai pas confiance à
ta petite affaire vous dire les choses
les 19h22 on est vendredi un chômage
reste confiant et donc je vais bien sûr
procéder aux cadeaux et pour tout vous
dire j'ai acheté un beau sac mais comme
c'est un sac et un bel investissement
j'ai regroupé je poserai le fier de moi
j'ai regroupé anniversaire noël et saint
valentin c'est quand son anniversaire
c'est en septembre j'ai regroupé
septembre c'est un beau très beau sac
mais c'est un très beau ça vous est
devenu une énorme bas
[Rires]
attendez le gâteau d'anniversaire le
baril en septembre soit on va te le foot
règle je connais pas tout alors donnez
moi trappe et un jean flare 2000 c'est
bon bon
lui comme il est amour lui je pense
qu'il va surtout qu'à doit lui-même a
comme il est fondu à lui guillaume
genton attention le jonc pelard 2000
la semaine dernière je lui ai dit je
suis passé devant une vitrine j'ai vu
que des choses pour toi résultat le
lendemain vitrine et et je passe la
vitrine est très bien s'est il avéré
juste à son bord non mais un truc de ouf
il a tout acheté sur moi mais tu nous
sommes tous sur tes l'oseille
je peux en parler sans rigoler j'ai
économisé j'ai économisé mes frères
tatata 12 ans à une semaine on donne 50
euros par watt économiser 200 voix voit
bien regardez vous êtes en même cadre à
une caste ou les deux alors non moi je
déteste la saint valentin sur ces
ringards et c c'est anxiogène en mai
vous avez l'art de la fête ses regards
on sait rien sur guillaume mons et saint
jean place et déjà vous dire c'est
guillaume jan aps la réunion vida hymne
qui est de retour ou la médaille ça va
ma chérie à leur restait à faire pour la
saint valentin
eh bien on est penché se voit
reconnaître que je suis un peu comme
comme guillaume je pense que la saint
valentin ce doit être toute l'année et
où il faut absolument faire des cadeaux
et à savoir néanmoins je pense que mon
amoureux comme une cuisine très très
bien me fera un petit dîner dont il y
aura concocté et suivi des patchs au psg
on me donnait des impôts moi sur la
saint-valentin rythme à cette journée
qui va coûter très cher parce que sachez
que le budget moyen pour la saint
valentin
ces 111 euros ouais c'est beaucoup à
part pour gilles verdez bien entendu si
vous êtes comme benjamin castadi et que
vous avez quatre femmes le budget
s'élève à 440 c'est comme ça a contrario
si vous êtes un dragueur et un chineur
compulsif comme nicolas pernikoff votre
budget va s'élever à 0 bien entendu il
est tranquille il doit avertir les
hommes quand votre main vous dit je m'en
fous de la saint valentin
parce que ouais y'a toujours voici un
test non décent royer pas bien sûr la
meuf elle dira toulouse nommées la maman
si tu lui dis genre le 1er février
chérie au 14 février saint malo non mais
je m'en fous des calmants et le jour où
vous allez vous-en pourriez avec elle
elle va dire nicolas salariales offertes
tu vas les cultes en foot et je rigolais
je connais je connais et seront violés
je connais vous vous allez faire quoi
prince cyril j'ai décidé de me
réconcilier avec l'amour alors il paraît
que vous avez repris avec le vétérinaire
exactement c'est pas vrai il va vous
offrir un chien mais qui se passe
non alors j'avais décidé tu avais décidé
sur le sable son dos visage
merci surtout virage c'est sûr c'était
pas le tien c'est comme c'est comme
gilles son anniversaire c'était il ya
trois quatre jours d'accord donc j'ai
tout misé sur l'anniversaire et je voulu
lui faire une petite soirée comme on
peut plus s'en sortir au restaurant lui
dire bon bah je vais lui faire un resto
à la maison sans frais gpat à parce que
j'ai déménagé il ya pas longtemps
oui j'ai pas de couverts et en plus j'ai
commandé mon cadeau aujourd'hui nos
tarifs mardy fish
fait chier avec votre histoire
non parce que si l'on pouvait plus
dites-moi castaldi ce qui se passe là il
se présente à une élection comme j'ai
animé avant jeudi je me l'étais
avec ça vous va extrêmement bien les
chéris donc c'est la saint valentin et
je voulais juste vous dire que je vous
ai dit si vous permettez parce que je
reviens lâche qu'est-ce que oui vous
êtes mauvais c'est vrai c'est pas la
question qu'est-ce que vous conseillez
vous par exemple à ceux qui nous
regardent de faire pour la saint
valentin qui d'après vous à tous les
coups vous fait plaisir à l'autre alors
vous vous revenez vous commencez à me
faire chier belle peau de france c'est
ça votre france a dit les médias j'avais
pour la saint valentin je vais vous dire
c'est très simple alors je vous donne un
concert tu veux donner un petit conseil
à la voyez sachez le
ne faites pas de trop gros cadeau c'est
suspect cadeau égale grosse connerie ça
veut dire j'ai envie de me faire
pardonner c'est vrai alors oui il a fait
une grosse connerie nominé face à
fédérer déjà ça mais tu me connais
l'homme et voilà donc non mais je vous
le dis je vous donne un conseil les
cherry ne fait pas de trop gros cadeau
c'est suspect alors au début elle va
dire ah je suis très contente et cetera
tata petit à tata au bout de deux jours
alors à parler à toutes ses copines ses
copines jalousie tu crois que c'est
normal tatati et tatata ils étaient où
le week-end dernier vacher pas trop j'ai
pas du talent à la bible des dossiers
qui ressortent
et voilà vous vous retrouvez lacanau qui
vous a coûté une tonne plus bien des
histoires de votre 9 qui vous dirai
comment ça se fait que tu m'as fait un
cadeau si cher tu as quelque chose à
faire pardonner
donc je vous le dis soyez non mais giuly
c'est l'expérience qui parle castaldi
groupe afrique et je me rappelle d'un
cadeau que j'ai fait effectivement une
saint valentin
ouais j'ai acheté un lustre nom d'une
célèbre marque une tonne une tonne
non vraiment ouais vraiment et quelques
temps après c'était à la partie
d'affilée c'est vrai est trop gros
cadeau et avait un truc oui mais ça
c'est vrai que tu es toi envie d'un
lustre
c'est sûr qu'elle était déjà pas qu'une
muller
[Applaudissements]